the royal family had been braced for
this but the raw revelations in Harry's
Memoir go further than anyone expected
he writes about a physical altercation
between him and Prince William with
William calling Megan difficult rude and
abrasive a row that escalates with
William grabbing Harry by the collar and
throwing him to the floor Harry landing
on a dog bowl which breaks and cuts into
him Harry also writes about the Nazi
uniform he wore to a friend's birthday
an incident which caused outrage but it
was a costume he says approved by
William and Kate we also learn about how
Harry took cocaine aged 17. he said it
wasn't fun he didn't feel as happy as
other people did but he wanted to feel
different and Harry writes also about
how he lost his virginity to an older
woman
he also describes how him and Prince
William both begged their father not to
marry Camilla Harry also writes about
his time in the military how he killed
25 people while serving in Afghanistan
and he goes back to his childhood and
the moment his father told him about the
death of his mother his dad said my dear
son mum has had a car accident
these are uncomfortable accusations for
the royal family and especially Prince
William Harry describes him as a beloved
brother and also his arch nemesis